こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
皆様は表情どれくらい大切にしていますか？
人には様々な表情があります。
笑顔　悲しい顔　怒った顔
ちょっぴり
切なそうな顔
表情はとても大切です
一つのドラマのシーンがあるとしましょう
そのシーンを様々な表情でやってみたら
ひょっとしたら
表情の大切さがわかるかもしれませんね
というわけで今日は～
あ、１回やったわフっ
一回やりましたね。昔もやったんですけども
１つの演技を１つのドラマのシーンみたいなのを
いまからやるんですけども
もしのシーンを仮に様々な表情でやってみたら
そのドラマのシーンはどのように変わるのか
一緒に見ていきましょう
今回やるシーンはこちらです
俺はバラフライアームス
通称　’バター’　というバンドを組んでいる
メンバーは、ギターのおれ、
ベースの竹中
ボーカルのあかりの３人だ
ちなみにおれはあかりと付き合っている。
初の路上ライブが間近に迫っていて
練習もラストスパート
そんななか俺は
2人のとんでもない関係を知ってしまった
なんだよ上田　急に呼び出して
おまえ
おれのあかりに手だしたろ？
は？
なんのことだよ
とぼけんじぇねー！！
んだよ～！！
スタジオの練習終わりに見ちまったんだよ
お前らが耳たぶくっつけながら歩いてるところを
見られてたのかよ
俺たちもう解散だな
ああ
お前とはうまくやっていけるとは思ったのによ
いかがっだったでしょうか
前回より結構ブラックなシーンですね
バンドチーム内の男女関係、非常に複雑ですね
というわけで今回は
こちらのシーンを様々な表情でやってみたいと思います
ではやっていきましょう
なんだよ上田　急に呼び出して
お前
俺のあかりに手だしたろ？
は？
なんのことだよ？
とぼけんじゃねー！
んだよ～！
スタジオの練習終わりに見ちまったんだよ
お前らが耳たぶくっつけながら歩いてるところを
見られてたのかよ
俺たちもう解散だな
ああ
お前とはうまくやっていけるとは思ったのによ
なんだよ上田、急に呼び出して
お前
俺のあかりに手出したろ？
は？
なんのことだよ
とぼけんじゃねー！
んだよ～！
スタジオの練習終わりに見ちまったんだよ
お前らが耳たぶくっつけながら歩いてるところを
見られてたのかよ
俺たちもう解散だな
ああ
お前とはうまくやっていけるとは思ったのによ
ｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｧｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ｱｯﾌｧｯﾊｯﾊﾂｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
なんだよ上田ｗｗｗ急に呼び出してｗｗｗ
おｗｗｗまｗｗｗえｗｗｗ
俺のあかりにｗｗｗ手出したろｗｗｗ
は？ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯｗｗｗなんのことだよｗ
とぼけんじゃねー！
ｱｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ﾌｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯｗｗｗｗｗｗ
んだよ～！ｗｗ
スタジオｗｗｗ終わりに見ちまったんだよｗｗｗ
お前らが耳たぶくっつけながら歩いてるｗｗところをｗｗｗｗ
見られてたのかよ
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯｗｗｗｗ
俺たちもう解散ｗｗだなｗｗｗ
ああ
ﾌｧｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ﾌｯﾌｯﾌｯﾌｯｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ｱｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
お前とはｗｗｗうまくｗｗｗやっていけるとは思ったのによｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
なんだよ上田、急に呼び出して
お前
俺のあかりに手だしたろ？
はあ？
なんのことだよ
とぼけんじゃねー！
んだよ～！
スタジオの練習終わりに見ちまったんだよ
お前らが耳たぶくっつけながら歩いてるところを
見られてたのかよ
俺たちもう解散だな
ああ
お前とはうまくやっていけるとは思ったのによ
なんだよ上田、急に呼び出して
お前
俺のあかりに手だしたろ？
ｼﾞｭﾙｼﾞｭﾙｼﾞｭﾙ
は？
なんのことだよ
はああはああ～
とぼけんじゃねー！
(コロンビア)
んだよ～！
ｳｩｩｳｩｩー└(՞ةڼ◔)」
スッタジオの練習終わりに見ちまったんだよ
ｼｨｰﾊｧｰ└(՞ةڼ◔)」
お前らが耳たぶくっつけながら歩いてるところを
ｲﾋｰｗｗｗｗｗ└(՞ةڼ◔)」
見られてたのかよ
ｳﾍｪｳｩｩｩｩｩ└(՞ةڼ◔)」
俺たちもう解散だな
ｳｳｳｩｩrrrrrrrﾊｧｰｗｗｗｗ└(՞ةڼ◔)」
ああ
お前とはうまくやっていけるとは思っヒったのによ
ｲｯh(ry└(՞ةڼ◔)」